- [Male Voice] This is Ed Glaser.
He's a film historian
with a peculiar specialty.
- I talk about, highlight
and occasionally
re-release foreign rip-offs and remakes.
- [Male Voice] Remakes like
Turkish Rambo, Nigerian Titanic,
and even Egyptian Rocky
Horror Picture Show.
But there's one that
stands out from the rest.
- The Holy Grail of these kinds of films is
Çetin İnanç’s ‘The
Man who Saves the World,’
better known as the Turkish Star Wars.
- [Male Voice] Turkish Star
Wars is a 1980s action film
that tells the story of two
Turkish space adventurers
who crash land on a desert planet
and decide to overthrow
its evil, tyrannical ruler.
- I’d never really seen anything like it.
It's a little bit like a fever dream.
- [Male Voice] And it's
famous for, well, this.
- [Ed] It's called Turkish Star Wars,
not because of the plot,
but because it actually
lifts footage from Star Wars
to sell the illusion that
they're flying fighters in space.
- [Male Voice] When the
film was in theaters,
only a handful of prints were made
and, given that there was
virtually no film preservation
in Turkey at the time,
every copy was thought
to have been destroyed.
But, after decades in obscurity,
media reports surfaced
of a rogue projectionist
who kept the only
existing copy of the film
in his personal collection.
Ed made it his mission to
restore the film to its glory.
- Once I got hold of the film,
I got in touch with a company,
who was very, very excited
about scanning and preserving it.
Obviously, it's 30 years old,
it's in a little bit rough shape.
What I want to be able to do
is restore it to the
best possible condition
and, ideally, in front
of as many people's eyes
as I possibly can.
- [Male Voice] Yeah, but why
go through all this trouble
for Turkish Star Wars?
- It's so unique.
Visually, it's so lurid and
vivid and wild and crazy
and there's just nothing else like it.
The first time I saw it
was on a screen this big
and now I wanna see it on the big screen,
the way that it was in 1982.
- [Male Voice] How do you say
"may the force be with you"
in Turkish?